bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition de votre journal local voici le
sommaire en ce 22 octobre 2014 la
fascinante et terrifiante histoire du
nucléaire militaire Jacques Villain
habitant de Voisins le bretonneux et
l'auteur du Livre noir du nucléaire
militaire aux éditions faayard ingénieur
et après une carrière dans la défense et
l'industrie spatiale il sera en plateau
ce soir le Secours populaire des
zvelines va devoir fermer son antenne
des clés sous boois pour raisons
sanitaires explication réaction aussi à
ce départ 20 ans après les premières
distributions alimentaires une balade en
forêt pour calculer la taille d'un arbre
ou la surface d'une parcelle l'ONF vient
de tenir un atelier pour amener les
enfants en douceur aux
mathématiques la polémique du jour elle
est signée du nouveau député desiveline
Benoît amont l'ancien ministre après
s'être abstenu sur le vote du budget a
déclaré a déclaré ce matin sur RFI que
la ligne suivie par l'exécutif menaçait
la République avant d'ajouter c'est la
préparation d'un immense désastre
démocratique pour 2017 celui qui a
quitté le gouvernement fin août a
ensuite été repris par le porte-parole
du gouvernement Stéphane lefolle mais
Benoît Hamont prévient il ne quittera
pas le PS benoî Hamont qui sera l'invité
du prochain 78 politique je recevrai
l'ancien ministre frondeur deorénavant
mardi des
18h30 le Secours populaire français ne
sera donc plus présent aux clés
sous-bois dans les prochains jours après
plus de 20 ans de présence l'antenne
locale doit fermer les explications avec
ce reportage de clerc Cambier et de
William
l à la fin du mois cette antenne du
Secours populaire français fermera ses
portes aux clés sous-bois l'association
était présente depuis une vingtaine
d'années la mairie leur avait cédé ce
local pour faciliter les distribution
alimentaire et de première nécessité au
cléciens dans le besoin mais ce local
partagé avec un autre organisme est
aujourd'hui trop vétuste et ne répond
plus aux normes d'hygiène et de sécurité
il ferme au 31 octobre et pendant une
semaine en fait pour
faciliter le déstockage on invite les
habitants des clés qui bénéficiaient de
l'aide du Secours populaire à venir tout
au long de la semaine pour avoir un
petit peu plus d'aide alimentaire que ce
qu' y avait d'habitude pour que les
stocks soi au plus bas pour ce qu'il va
falloir rendre les
locaux du 24 octobre au 1 nov les
bénévoles distribueront également des
vêtements affaires scolaires ou encore
vaisselles la mairie n'a pas trouvé de
solution alternative à proposer de son
côté le Secours populaire n'a pas les
fonds pour financer un local par ses
propres moyens un coup dur pour les
quelques 70 familles soutenues par
l'antenne dans l'actualité également
deux parkings sou-terrain situés à
Montini le Bretonneux et à Guy encours
ont été visité la nuit dernière bilan 22
véhicules ont été dégradés ce n'est pas
la première fois que ce phénomène
survient Antony
reche c'est probablement derrière cette
porte que les vandales ont agi dans la
nuit de mardi à mercredi six véhicules
ont été dégradés dans un parking
souterrain situé rue suli à Montini
lebreteneux la totalité des voitures a
été fouillé et vidé par les hauteurs des
faits le même scénario s'est également
produit à quelques centaines de mètres
de là dans la ville voisine de Guill
encour dans cet autre parking pas moins
de 16 véhicules stationnés ont été
dégradés est également fouillé au 3941
du boulevard vaauan ce n'est d'ailleurs
pas la première fois cette année que les
parkings souterrains de cette rue sont
la cible de dégradation les faits ont
été constatés ce matin vers 5h selon les
premiers éléments recueillis il pourrait
s'agir de la même équipe de roulautier
une enquête a été ouverte par les
services de
police bientôt une zone d'aménagement
concerté sur le secteur Booba Louise
Michel à trppe c'est une décision de
l'établissement public Paris SACL cl le
site de 21 hectares appartenant en
grande partie à la SNCF doit devenir un
pôle de développement majeur avec la
création de logement d'activités
économique et d'équipement une réunion
publique un atelier également pour
recueillir les propositions des riverins
habitants et salariés vont être
prochainement annoncé invité de ce 22
octobre à présent Jacques Villain
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes ingénieur
historien vous avez fait votre carrière
au ministère de la Défense dans
l'industrie spatiale vous êtes
d'ailleurs l'auteur de plusieurs
ouvrages sur l'espace mais ce soir je
vous reçois pour parler de cet ouvrage
Le livre noir du nucléaire militaire qui
est disponible depuis quelques semaines
aux éditions faayard un livre pour
raconter 70 ans d'une histoire mondiale
pour dévoiler aussi des secrets et puis
pour nous placer tous face à nos
responsabilités vous partez d'un constat
dans l'opinion publique Fukushima
Tchernobyl deux catastrophes du
nucléaire civil cette fois-ci qui ont
complètement occulté l'histoire du
nucléaire militaire on a oublié cette
réalité là aussi vous avez tout à fait
raison on a présenté êre Fukushima
tchernoby mais c'est ce que j'appelle la
partie émergée de lisberg mais en
dessous il y a il y a des catastrophes
nucléaires militaires qui sont beaucoup
plus importantes et même qui date de
bien avant aujourd'hui encore on paye
les conséquences de l'armement nucléaire
notamment avec l'URSS vous écrivit le
nucléaire militaire soviétique arrive
très largement en tête des statistiques
des drames sur toute la période et
pourtant il n'existe pas ou très peu de
de sources comment vous avez travaillé
pour établir tout ça le livre que vous
avez entre les mains c'est à peu près
5000 sources de information qu'il a
fallu aller chercher qu'il a fallu aller
chercher aux États-Unis en France assez
peu mais la Russie s'est ouverte depuis
un certain temps il y a des sites
internet en Russie donc ça a été
effectivement un long travail de
plusieurs années de compilation de
toutes ces données et et ça abouti à ça
effectivement la synthèse est assez est
assez loquante si je puis dire c'est
assez effrayant sur les conflits
États-Unis erss pendant la guerre froide
on se croirit dans un film pourtant
c'est bien la réalité plus d'une fois
l'opinion ne s'est pas douté qu'on était
tout proche d'un conflit nucléaire dans
les années 60 par exemple ah ben le ce
qui reste en tête c'est l'affaire de
Cuba en octobre 62 euh certains s'en
souviennent probablement euh les
Soviétiques implantent des missiles à
Cuba pour viser les États-Unis et il y a
un dialogue de Sour quasiment entre
crrutchev et Kennedy et la tension monte
et on se demande si effectivement un
moment ou un autre il va pas y avoir une
guerre nucléaire mais ce qui se passe
sous la mer est encore plus dramatique
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un sous-marin et
ça on en a très peu parlé il y a un
sous-marin soviétique qui lui ne peut
pas communiquer avec MOS parce qu'à
l'époque les Soviétiques avaient des
systèmes de communication qui étaient
pas très développés et le règlement de
la marine soviétique permettait qu'on
tire une torpille nucléaire sur un
bateau américain à condition que les
trois officiers à bord les plus gradés
soient d'accord et bien l'un des
officiers un jeune lieutenant n'a pas
été d'accord donc grâce à lui on a vite
le pire et ça c'est quand même une
épage absolument sur un détail c'est
effrayant on l'a bien compris il a la
façon aussi et c'est relaté dans
l'ouvrage dont la course à l'armement
comment s'est déroulé des cantes
prisonniers en URSS terrible terrible
pour pouvoir développer le le nucléaire
le le nucléaire en nucléaire militaire
en Union soviétique commence
pratiquement en même temps qu'aux
États-Unis c'est-à-dire que en 42 il y a
le programme Matan qui va aboutir à la
bombe d'Hiroshima et les Soviétiques par
le réseau d'espionnage savent que les
Américains sont en train de développer
une arme tout à fait considérable donc
Staline va développer une infrastructure
nucléaire pour faire ses propres bombes
et qu'est-ce qu'il va faire et bien il
va récupérer les anciens prisonniers
sovieétiques qui ont été fait
prisonniers par l'armée allemande en 41
et ces gens-là pour lui c'est des gens
qui ont trahi donc il doivent être
condamnés à mort donc il va les emmener
au goulag il va y avoir des goulag qui
vont être créés en Sibérie pour pouvoir
construire ces infrastructures
militaires nucléaires donc ils vont
construire les réacteurs nucléaires les
bâtiments tout ce que vous voulez et une
fois que ça va être construit alors là
on est dans l'horreur absolument absolu
c'est que ces gens-là sont bien sûr
détenteurs de secret puisque ils savent
où se trouvent les installations
nucléaires donc ces gens-là on va en
tuer un certain nombre et puis ceux qui
vont rester et bien on va créer un
encore un goulac spécial vraiment très
très haut en Sibérie et puis on aura
plus jamais de trace de tous ces gens-là
donc le nucléaire militaire en l'Union
soviétique c'est un désastre complet et
le nucléaire pour s'en protéger c'est
l'alcool uniquement qui est utilisé
alors c'est c'ests oui alors il y a pas
que dans le nucléaire on l'a vu encore
récemment avec l'affaire de des neigeuse
à Moscou avec l'accident de de Monsieur
de marjori il y a une consommation de
votc absolument terrible et lorsque les
les Soviétiques vont commencer à
recruter les les les premiers équipages
de sous-marins nucléaair en 1955 et bien
personne ne veut y aller parce que on
commence à avoir idée qu'il y a des
pannes c'est pas c'est quand même pas
c'est pas fiable c'est pas fa qu'est-ce
que va faire la marine soviétique et va
édicter un règlement comme quoi le
meilleur antidote au rayonnement c'est
la vodka donc la marine soviétique
s'engage à fournir 200 ml de vodka par
jour au sous-mariners et à partir de ce
moment-là tout le monde va signer ce
sont tous ces petits détails qui font
que le livre est très facile à lire on
rentre très facilement dans dans la
lecture malgré l'imposant ouvrage he que
que j'ai entre entre les mains vous
vouliez cette lecture aussi facile vous
vouliez amener les gens à à lire et que
ce soit pas uniquement des cartes et des
chiffres et qu'on c'est les histoires
des hommes derrière c'est ce que je
souhaitais d'abord parce que c'est une
histoire d'hommees et puis on est quand
même dans un domaine qui est pas
facilement lisible par celui qui n'est
pas qui n'est pas au courant donc il
fallait à tout prix je dirais
euh adopter un langage qui soit
compréhensible par tout le monde donc
c'est pas romancé mais il y a quand même
je voulais j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai pas pris
la plume du technicien j'ai pris la
plume du technicien qui s'adresse au
lecteur qui n'est pas averti c'est
l'histoire des hommes l'histoire
d'humain derrière des des réalités des
réalités quelquefois effroyables et
pourtant c'est vraiment vraiment on
insiste ce qui s'est déroulé sur toute
cette période sur ces 70 ans d'histoire
du du nucléaire on parle beaucoup de
l'URSS dans cet ouvrage des États-Unis
aussi forcément la France dans tout ça
ben écoutez la France et ça je crois que
c'est un c'est c'est un point très
important à souligner c'est qu'on on a
assisté à des accidents et de nombreux
accidents en Union soviétique par
exemple en 57 l'explosion qui a eu lieu
d'un dépôt nucléaire a été
considérablement plus grave que
Tchernobyl hein considérablement plus
grave aux États-Unis ils ont perdu C à
si bombes atomiques on sait pas où elles
sont font des océans et cetera et nous
en France nous avons aussi construit une
force de dissuision nucléaire mais
beaucoup moins imposante que celle des
deux super grands et nous n'avons jamais
eu d'accident ça veut dire que le
nucléaire quand on est obligé de
l'utiliser dans le cas de la force de
dissuision c'est dans la production
d'électricité aujourd'hui c'est quand
même un point important on montre que on
peut le gérer à condition d'adopter des
des je dirais des mesures de sécurité de
fonctionnement de sûreté et cetera et ça
c'est un des je dirais un point un point
que j'ai voulu souligner dans cet
ouvrage ce que vous avez aussi voulu
souligner je vais vous citer une
nouvelle fois aujourd'hui 21e siècle la
bombe atomique n'est pas une arme comme
les autres hein elle vise non pas à
faire la guerre mais à l'éviter on voit
bien qu'il y a de plus en plus de pays
qui se dote de l'arme nucléaire qui font
des recherches sur le nucléaire
militaire est-ce qu'aujourd'hui tous les
pays sont dans la même optique c'est de
la dissuasion non pour répondre
franchement à votre question c'est clair
que les grandes puissances aujourd'hui
ne sont plus dans l'utilisation de
l'arme nucléaire sur le champ de
bataille ils sont dans la dissuasion
c'està direire faire peur pour éviter
d'être envahis est-ce que c'est la même
optique venant de la Corée du Nord
est-ce que c'est la même optique venant
du Pakistan demain de l'Iran je n'en
suis pas tout à fait sûr donc c'est là
où la le danger pour le le 21e siècle se
pose c'est bien l'utilisation par ces
nouveaux arrivants de l'arme atomique
dissuision ou au contraire utilisation
de ce ch y a deux danger aujourd'hui
autour du nucléaire qu'on voit bien
aussi he dans l'ouvrage il y a le danger
avec ces nouvelles puissances qui se
dotent de l'arme nucléaire de
l'équipement nucléaire militaire et puis
aussi bah ce qui reste des équipements
qui n'ont pas été sécurisés vous l'avais
évoqué brièvement mais il y a des des
bombes qui ont été perdues des choses
assez assez surprenantes le sous-marin
le k159 voilà on va citer un autre
exemple ah B le K 1559 c'est c'est de
nos jours c'est en 2003 après la guerre
froide c'est un sous-marin qui est hors
d'usage mais on continue à faire
fonctionner les réacteurs àqu et puis un
moment les les Russes on n'est plus chez
les Soviétiques on est chez les Russes
donc il il y a très peu de temps décide
effectivement de d'envoyer ce sous-marin
pour le démanteler et euh une fois
encore si je puis dire chez les Russes
et bien euh je sais pas si les gens ont
pris trop de vodka mais le sous-marin
qui est remorqué va couler et là euh ben
il y a ne9u morts et puis il y a pas que
celui-là en décembre 2011 il y a un
sous-marin euh soviétique euh qui est en
cours de réparation et on a laissé les
20 missiles à bord avec chacun six têtes
nucléaires et on on soude h et là il y a
un incendie voyez ça ça n'arriverait
jamais en France parce que il y a des
procédures là-bas bah c'est pas c'est
pas la même ch que ça concerne la
planète entière parce que çaou problème
un accident nucléire en Union soviétique
on l'a vu avec chernoby ça s'arrête pas
à la frontière et même avec Fukushima
encore ça fait le tour de de la planète
quel était l'objectif avec avec cet
ouvrage c'était d'alerter c'était de
dire il faut arrêter maintenant le
nucléaire que ce soit militaire que ce
soit civil non si vous voulez vous là
vous parlez à quelqu'un qui a vécu sa
jeunesse avec la Seconde Guerre mondiale
les Allemands dans sa maison euh la
maison bombardée le 6 juin 44 pour moi
la dissuision nucléaire c'est vraiment
l'ultime rempart tout ça c'était
nécessaire malgré les accidents malgré
les problèmes de sécurité malré la
preuve je vous a dit qu'en France on n
jamais eu ces accidents là alors les
accidents dont on parle là c'est
essentiellement pendant la guerre froide
aujourd'hui il y en a quand même
beaucoup moins c'està dire que le
nucléaire militaire est beaucoup mieux
maîtrisé par les États-Unis et par et
par l'Union soviétique mais évidemment
vis-à-vis des pays dont on vient de
parler le Pakistan et cetera je peux pas
avoir la même certitude donc mon opinion
est on a besoin du nucléaire militaire
parce que on est un petit pays je sais
pas dans 20 ans ou dans 30 ans ce que
sera la la géopolitique et s'il y a un
grand pays qui vaudra du mal à au nôtre
mais il faut se garantir quand même de
notre survie passe par le nucléaire à
mon sens mais il faut que on ait les
garanti que cette armeement nucléaire
est sûr fiable et cetera donc ça passe
par les hommes ça passe par les
procédures ça passe par tout ça et tout
ça a permis aussi le nucléaire civil
parce que les recherches qui ont été
menées dans le militaire on permis de
développer aussi développer le reste et
justement notre question du jour nous
sommes allés vous voir dans les rues de
50 ans neline la France sans énergie
nucléaire est- souhaitable est-ce
envisageable voici vos réponses
aujourd'hui non mais je pense que dans
entre 10 et 20 ans c'est possible en
tout cas on aura pas le choix oui on
pourrait si on fait comme les Allemands
non je pense pas malheureusement on est
à 80 % de d'énergie nucléaire donc sans
passer maintenant ça paraît difficile il
aurait fallu s en occuper un peu plus
tôt maintenant on a trop mis le doigt
dedans alors ça va être dur de le sortir
c'est quand même une énergie
heureusement et malheureusement
propre et je vois pas comment on
pourrait s'en passer sinon il faut faire
comme l'Allemagne c'est retour en
arrière de nouveau au charbon d'un
côté c'est un peu plus écologique malgré
tous ces polluant et l'extraire des
mines c'est pas évident non plus avec
tous les risques humain de sécurité du
travail que ça comporte donc je crains
qu'on ne puisse pas s'en passer quite un
peu l'objet de votre ouvrage sur le
nucléaire militaire mais globalement il
y a une résignation vis-à-vis du
nucléaire on y est on l'a fait bon ben
maintenant faut l'accepter mais je crois
que les personnes que vous avez
interviewé exprime vraiment un point de
vue tout à fait raisonnable il est
certain que quelqu'un citit l'Allemagne
ils ont abandonné le nucléaire militaire
mais quand on voit ce que donnent les
les les les centrales au charbon alors
soit effectivement on est est dans un
cas où le nucléaire militaire les les je
dirais les les problèmes peuvent venir à
long terme soit on est dans le dans le
charbon et les problèmes viennent tout
de suite et c'est l'effet l'effet de
serre les gaz carboniques et cetera donc
il y a pas de source d'énergie parfaite
donc il y a à choisir entre entre autres
entre la peste et le chéra quoi c'est un
peu ça merci Jacques Villain auteur du
livre noir du nucléaire militaire
disponible donc aux éditions Fire et
puis pour aller plus loin il y a aussi
un autre ouvrage la force nucléaire
française avec l'aide des États-Unis
c'est aussi votre ouvrage merci beaucoup
tout cela est passionnant même si on le
redit c'est effrayant merci à vous puis
je rappelle que vous êtes ilinois vous
êtes installé à voisin de Bretonneux
loin d'ici la suite de ce journal c'est
avec un sujet plus rassurant cette
fois-ci c'est l'opération balle jaune
depuis 3 ans la Ligue de tennis des
ivelin récupère par l'intermédiaire des
clubs des balles usagers leur recyclage
qui permettra la création de terrains de
sport comme nous l'explique
Antony ce terrain est une vraie bouffée
d'air pour ces jeunes au départ il
jouait sur le parking de l'établ
issement désormais grâce aux 58000
balles récoltées dans le cadre de
l'opération balle jaune par les clubs
cette année la Ligue de tennis des
ivelines a permis la création de ce
terrain de sport adapté de 200 m Carr
avant on ne savait pas où elle passait
les balles passé à la décharge
vraisemblablement or quand ça représente
que 10 % des balles utilisées c'est
encore il y a pas mal de choses à voir
et on est en réflexion pour trouver
également d'autres utilisations des
balles pour faire d'autres choses que
des appuy cet établissement créé il y a
12 ans s'occupe de 21 jeunes âgés de 14
à 20 ans souffrant de troubl de
communication ou de la relation
désormais cette ime compte deux ateliers
tennis par semaine dont un au sein du
club des clés sous-bois une structure
qui a permis à la jeune Anaïse de
devenir championne de France de tennis
adapté cet été pour nous c'est génial
parce que du coup c'est très valorisant
pour les jeunes et c'est très valorisant
pour les professionnels maintenant je
vais leur mettre la pression maintenant
il son obligé un résultat on est obligé
d'avoir un résultat on a eu un champion
de France l'année dernière l'année
prochaine il faut qu'il y en ait deux
sinon il va faire autre chose ce terrain
est le deuxème solul réalisé dans les
Yvelines depuis le lancement de
l'opération balle jaune en 2008 à
l'heure actuelle 10 % des balles
consommés sont transformés en sol souple
ou en tapis
sportif une exposition pour poursuivre
jusqu'au 2 novembre au cœur du parc
naturel régional de la Haute Vallée de
Chevreuse quatre œuvres éphémères
évoquant l'eau sont à découvrir le
résultat d'un appel à lancé par quatre
agriculteurs claire Cambier et William
pour les
images installer des œuvres d'art en
plein champ c'est le défi fou qu'ont
réalisé Gill Brusset et Édouard sor sur
le plateau de Limour le parc naturel de
la vallée de Chevreuse et des
agriculteurs du coin souhaitait
valoriser le territoire et révéler l'eau
omniprésente discrète et essentielle
pour la culture du sol à gomèz la ville
on croit ces miroirs comme des gouttes
d'eau qui réflètent la lumière comme les
miroirs sont orientés de façon ç à
refléter le ciel on a une équivalence
entre l'arrière-plan du ciel qui est à
l'horizon
et le ciel qui est reflété dans les
miroirs c'est pour ça qu'ils sont tous
alignés avec la ligne d'horizon et que
on a un effet de descendre du ciel sur
la terre en petite goutte d'où le nom de
la sculpture l'eau qui tombe on peut
aller se balader en s'approchant la
vision de l'œuvre change jeux de regard
et jeux d'optique chacun des miroirs et
une sorte d'échantillon des couleurs et
des lumières du ciel comme une palette
hein ça donne il y a si vous voyez les
miroirs il y a peut-être sans miroir Ça
fait sans nuance de gris en choisissant
un miroir une fenêtre sur le ciel on
observe un paysage différent et pourtant
bien familier ces fameux miroirs il faut
se les se les imaginer devant ce beau
plateau agricole et puis le reflet qu'
peuvent amener tout autour on voulait
essayer de comment on dit de trouver une
coordination entre les ruraux et les
citadins en tout qure uvres ont pris
place sur le plateau toutes reprennent
le miroir comme support mais le
véritable matériau de l'œuvre reste le
ciel le reflet qu'il renvoie à bouler
les trous on retrouve l'eau qui court
ces miroirs suivent les inclinaisons de
ce fossé de récupération des EAU usées
c'est pour expliquer quand même l'eau le
rôle de l'eau avec l'agriculture je
pense qu'elle s'intéresse beaucoup plus
à l'agriculture qu'il y a quelques
années
peut-être je pense que les personnes
sont beaucoup plus sensibilisées dans ce
domaine là un rôle pédagogique de
sensibilisation qui peut intriguer des
habitants pour mieux saisir ses œuvres
des visites explicatives et des balades
sont organisé jusqu'au 2 novembre
Édouard s s'occupe de photographier les
œuvres et les ateliers il souhaiterait
faire vivre projet au-delà de ces
installations sur ces territoire on voit
des champs on voit du ciel mais l'eau on
la devine que rarement d'autant plus que
sur le plateau elle est invisible donc
un des enjeux a été de rendre cette eau
visible les œuvres ils sont pour quelque
chose la carte devra le faire aussi et
cette carte c'est la carte du plateau de
limau dans ce livre des éléments
relatifs aux œuvres des photos du making
of mais aussi des explications sur l'eau
et le plateau et des rencontres avec les
agriculteurs et les habitants carré il
pourra s'effeuiller pour constituer une
carte complète du territoire pour le
financer il fait appel au particulier
via un site participatif àe aux
amateurs une balade en forêt à présent
pour terminer ce journal calculer la
taille d'un arbre la surface d'une
parcelle un atelier vient d'être proposé
par l'ONF afin de sensibiliser les plus
jeunes à l'importance des
mathématiquesatherine zulato sur des
images
d' et si les mathématiques étaient tout
autour de nous un atelier pratique
organisé ce weekend par l'Office
national des forêts à la Maison de la
madriade à trappe les apprentis
forestiers ont appris à fabriquer des
outils comme ceux utilisés
quotidiennement par les techniciens de
l'ONF par exemple des triangles iSOCEL
qui mettent en application le théorème
de Thalès le haut du regard sera en haut
de l'arbre et la distance qui nous
séparera de cet arbre là sera égale à la
hauteur de l'arbre la réalisation de la
mesure de la hauteur se fait avec deux
de donc un triangle
iSOCEL qu'on met parallèle au sol et on
va s'écarter jusqu'à tempant que la
l'œil voit le la base de l'arbre et
l'œil voit la hauteur de l'arbre en même
temps à travers le triangle et après il
suffit de compter la distance qui sépare
de l'arbre pour avoir la distance de la
hauteur de l'arbre démonstration
pratique avec Éric de porte un des
stagiaires c'est compliqué de mesurer un
AR non avec les bons instruments queon a
fabriqué maintenant c'est simple avant
compliqué ou mesurer la taille d'un
arbre connaître son âge en pratiquant
des carotages dans le Tron mais
également calculer la surface terrière
pour cela il vous faut une tige de bois
de 15 cm de haut avec une séparation de
1 cm entre de clous et une corde de 50
cm à égale distance et de faire un
cercle et de compter tous les arbres qui
vont dépasser mes deux petits clous tout
ces arbres làendont une surface de bois
de volume de bois sur la base sur le
terrain tout le monde s'y met on
découvre plein de choses des outils tout
ça quand c'est entre les deux clous et
ben ça on compte pour un quand c'est
pile sur les deux clous c'est un demi et
si c'est plus petit que les deux clous
c'est zé j'avais déjà appris à mesurer
la hauteur d'un arme juste avec de de
baguettes de bois parce qu'on peut le
faire comme ça en forêt pour s'amuser
mais là ce qui est bien c'est qu'on a
fabriquer un outil qui ressemble
vraiment un vrai outil de Forestier donc
c'est vrai que c'est c'est intéressant
de voir aussi ces outils donc de faire
une copie des outils pour pouvoir les
utiliser tout en forêt c'est c'est
concret quoi une opération séduction
aussi pour les techniciens de l'ONF la
filière bois ce sont tout de même 450000
emplois en
France ce mercredi sur TVfil vous avez
rendez-vous avec Catherine zulato pour
un nouveau numéro de kiosque le point
sur l'actualité culturelle de la semaine
à demain 18h pour votre journal une
nouvelle fois en direct très bonne
soirée